mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
heute zu einem neuen video ihr seht
schon dritte eingeblendet wilde auf
meiner kindheit
die zeige ich euch heute ich habe
einfach meine mutter gefragt ob sie
irgendwo bei uns im haus noch
irgendwelche bilder hat von mir aus der
kindheit und sie kamen natürlich sowie
mütter alt sind mit zwei so riesigen
paketen an euro
es folgen kinder und feind nämlich jetzt
denke was kann denn alles drin sein das
sind wirklich übel viele bilder drehen
und das ist so fucking schwer
mein ganzer tisch ist gerade fast
eingekracht ich habe auf jeden fall
gedacht wenn ich euch alle bilder zeigen
würde müsste ich einen 4000 stunden live
stream machen deswegen zeige ich euch
einfach nur so fünf bis 15 stück meine
mutter hat mir bilder gegeben von dem 21
februar 1996 also dem tag wo ich geboren
bin das bild möchte euch tatsächlich
ungern zeigen weil ich da gerade
wirklich frisch geboren bin und noch
voller blut darum liege das erste bild
was sie mir gegeben hat war von dem 48
1996 also ist sega sechs monate nach dem
ich geboren wurde und zwar dieses hier
kleinen luca sieht man überhaupt
irgendeine ähnlichkeit da hat mich halt
mein vater irgendwie im arm und ich
sitze in meiner
kindheits schlafsäcke da und lache und
das ist quasi das erste bild was ich
euch heute zeige die nächsten bilder
sind auf der rückseite stets aus dem
jahr 1997 da habe ich nämlich zwei
bilder vorbereitet wenn ihr oft in den
skiurlaub fahren sieht es wahrscheinlich
selber relativ häufig und zwar ist der
schmiere auf meiner linse auf einmal
will ich ganz schön ihr seht dann
vielleicht manchmal im skiurlaub auf der
piste so kleine kinder die da wirklich
schon auf den skiern rumfahren und ich
denke mir da im artikel jetzt schon
besser fahren als ich sein luca war
früher nicht so ein typ dafür direkt
seine begabung zusammen sondern er war
eher der der sich hat ziehen lassen im
fokus ihrer etwa die scheiße hier mal
ein paar sekunden später wurde und mein
schlitten januar 1997 habe mich
natürlich ziehen lassen wie sollen
übelster fettsack und was im januar 1997
natürlich auch noch passiert ist ist
dass luca was gegessen hat und ich mein
ich habe da nicht so gegessen wie andere
kinder und meine eltern bilder von mir
gemacht wo ich sehen einfach selbst so
haben mich meine eltern fotografiert die
ich mir da so fetsch bei der die in den
mund gehalten habe om nom nom nom noch
die nächsten bilder die ich euch zeigen
sind aus dem februar 1997 und zwar noch
nicht von meinem geburtstag also ich war
noch nicht ein jahr alt aber ich glaube
kurz davor ihr wisst ja ich habe einen
gewissen geschmack für mode das ist der
grund warum ich jetzt gerade einfach ein
weißes t-shirt an habe einen und marina
ich habe mir schon früher gedacht bevor
ich ein jahr alt war
it's time for a change guckt euch mal
meinen pulli da ich stehe da an einem
glas tisch und habe den pulli an
rachel wood fokussiert kamera major
simplicity jetzt heim for change vor
allem steht das auch richtig breitbeinig
und offensiv eingestellt dann hatte ich
natürlich auch noch freunde
man mag es kaum glauben da hat meine mom
beispielsweise den kollegen von mir
fotografiert das ist der hier ich weiß
nicht mehr wer das war er selbst auf
jeden fall ganz gekonnt rum und hat fürs
foto posiert und dann gibt es auch noch
luca der hat natürlich mal wieder
gefressen und stand in der ecke und hat
sich eine prinzenrolle reingeschoben
foto ich muss richtig pushen und wodurch
erst mal meinen keks auf und hoffe dass
sie mich nicht mehr drauf hat müsste
übrigens wissen meine mom hat noch viel
mehr fotos gemacht ich zeig euch jetzt
aber nur die wo quasi nur ich drauf bin
und keine irgendwie anderen aus meiner
familie habe ich schon am anfang gesagt
wenn ich euch alles sein würde wird das
video doch kann mehr als 4000 stunden
dauern bei diesen bildern hier steht
kein ja aber auf dem umschlag steht das
jahr 1999 und zwar der achtzehnte vierte
danke mama das ist immer so gut
festgehalten
das hier ist luca in einem austin healey
oldtimer natürlich sicherheit sei aber
mit helm auf genug da aus dem fahrersitz
raus und mein ich durfte das auto leider
in dem alter noch nicht fahren
ich habe da wirklich geholt als ich
nicht fahren durfte
jetzt gibt auch noch andere bilder von
mir aus diesem auto und zwar
beispielsweise auch das hier da luke ich
aufs im auto wie so ein kleiner wurm
außen ab als ich dann halt diese
nachricht übermittelt bekommen habe dass
ich leider in diesem auto nicht fahren
darf habe ich mir dann meinen eigenen
kleinen motorisierten kfz wagen geholt
einen traktor bildete dynamit umbauen
dies lag vor allem auch so richtig
bescheid ich bücke mich weil ich denke
wenn ich gerade stehe bin ich nicht auf
dem bild mit drauf oder so ich meine
luca was ist mit dir los ich war noch
nie ein fan von höhen und das hat man
auch am 18.4 1999 auf einem spielplatz
gesehen da sitzt luka auf einer rutsche
und ich hoffe sie in meinem gesicht dass
ich nicht so erfreut darüber bin ich
hatte übeln angst darunter zu rutschen
weil ich einfach höhenangst habe
und die habe ich selbst heute noch ein
bisschen das waren 4 bilder vom 18 04
1999 also einmal dass hier wo ich in
diesem auto ist genug habe dann das hier
wo ich in dem auto quasi wirklich drin
saßen vor dem fahrersitz geschaut habe
dann dass sie auf dieser rutsche und ich
habe höhenangst und dass hier wo ich den
rasenmäher so [ __ ] mäßig gefahren bin
das letzte bild was ich heute
vorbereitet habe weil ich will euch ja
auch nicht alles aus meiner kindheit
präsentieren so ein bisschen muss
natürlich auch noch privat bleiben 24
zweiter 2002 ich war also sechs jahre
alt gerade geworden
drei tage nach meinem geburtstag und es
war karneval und ich habe mich als tiger
verkleidet lasst das bild einfach mal
auf euch wird ich war ein tiger das
lustig ist auch nicht habe mich an
nichts von diesen ganzen sachen hier
erinnern außer dass ich auf der rutsche
fast geheult habe und die rutsche war so
circa 1 meter 50 hoch das war's mit dem
video meine damen und herren es euch
gefallen hat
last auf jeden fall mike da und lassen
leider wenn ihr noch mal wollte dass ich
euch noch mehr bilder zeige
weil ich habe mir noch fünf millionen
kommentiert mal bitte mit dem wort
kindheit wenn ihr bis jetzt gerade noch
dran seid also das interessiert mich
immer wie lange leute dran bleiben von
meinen zuschauern volkmer auch musical
heißt laser luca mit doppel an das habe
ich mir jetzt neu gemacht jemand kleiner
ausschnitt und instagram den cetera seht
ihr in der beschreibung also